Mary Kay Cabot covers the Browns for the
Cleveland Plain Dealer what do you
expect in hard knocks Mary Kay well the
first thing I think we'll see a lot of
Baker Mayfield
Tyrod Taylor you know there's a lot of
drama and intrigue earning those guys
you know we may even take a peek inside
the club QPR v the faker has had to
provide so I think that's one storyline
then we've got the Josh Gordon saga
going on so I'm curious to see how they
handle all of that and there's been
plenty of our stuff going on too like
Corey Coleman getting treated just
within the last two days so I think it
will be a compelling show the one thing
I was curious about when you said Baker
Mayfield doesn't he have his own film
crew and is he going to contribute to
hard knocks when he would want to keep
that kind of content for his own camera
crew you know that's that's a great
point he has already been all over the
place on all the way up and and behind
Baker and those sorts of things so he
does not camera-shy that's for sure but
he has participated fully in this and
hard-knocks is taking advantage of the
star power that he has keep reading
quotes and quotes that say Baker
Mayfield is playing great in practice
which I don't know what that means
but then you also get quotes that are
attributed to Hugh Jackson saying you
know Tyrod Taylor's my quarterback that
ends the discussion is there any way
Baker Mayfield can win this job no
because they're setting it up so that he
really can't win this job and they're
also setting it up to sort of keep
Mayfield mania at bay and how do you do
that well let me just give you a really
quick example here in the scrimmage the
other night they had Tyrod Taylor going
with the first team offense going
against the second team defense and he
looked great of course against the
second team defense he was doing
touchdown passes to Jarvis Landry and
those guys were making it look easy
then when Baker Mayfield got his chance
he was with the second team offense
against the first team defense and he
was getting picked off by the likes of
Jamie Collins so in order to make sure
that you're keeping this QB situation
going the way that you want it to those
are some of the things you can do what
is the reaction to Baker Mayfield in
camp
how did teammates get along with him do
you get along with him great
he's got a great personality guys really
like him there's a dynamic going on with
the crew Stanton where he's handling
Baker really really well he's got a
great sense of humor drew does and those
guys are kind of meshing he gives him a
little bit of grief here and there he's
the one that ordered Baker to get the RV
so he's keeping Baker in his place and
kind of showing him what a rookie needs
to do what is this RV that now did he
purchase this that it's the quarterback
RV no he did not purchase it and it was
a company out of Lorain Ohio and I'm
sure that they have donated the RV
because as you know by now they're
getting uh plenty of great publicity for
this thing and I'm sure it will be all
over Hardin acts as well so I'm sure
that Baker probably just had to make a
couple of phone calls and the RV showed
up magically in Berea hmm have you been
on the RV the quarterback RV no I
haven't been in there yet but yesterday
when we were talking to Rashard Higgins
one of the receivers she thought that we
deserve to actually have an opportunity
to go in there so when you if she can
follow through on that you mentioned
Josh Gordon where are we with Josh
Gordon going into let's say week one of
the regular season well it's tough to
say he'll be ready or around for week
one of the regular season and with Josh
it's always difficult to know exactly
what is going on but the best night I
can tell it's always been a tough thing
to try to cover but he's in Gainesville
Florida right now my guess is that he is
working with the same counselors and
that he worked with what he spent 90
days in inpatient rehab last summer and
fall and I believe that he will be back
at some point
I think they probably gave him another
prescribed timeframe of some sort or at
least some parameters to go get yourself
together and when your medical team
feels good about where your head is at
we'll bring you back so when that is
it's in the hands of the medical team
and it could be you know I know it will
be this week but it could be a week or
two I'm guessing that it will probably
be at some point before the season
starts you know morale I don't know if
morale is high but it but it has to be
there has to be excitement there in
Cleveland it just feels a little bit
different here
I've had people say you know they could
win six seven games here realistic asked
about you know projection here from Mary
Kay Cabot who joins us on loan from the
Cleveland Plain Dealer what would be
realistic for this year's Cleveland
Browns yeah I think it seems like a huge
leap to go from zero to six or seven but
I actually could see it happening based
in part on the fact that so many of last
year's woes had to do with turning the
ball over and not taking it away
Deshawn Kaiser turned the ball over at
an alarming rate they and they the
defensive guys just weren't getting cake
away so they finished with a minus 28 in
a turnover differential which was way
way way below anybody else if you just
start winning the take away battle in a
game you're gonna win some games because
they don't have talent on this football
team and significantly more talent than
last year so I think six or seven is
actually realistic alright thanks for
joining us as always have fun today and
we appreciate your time
it's Mary Kay Cabot she's always in a
good mood probably because the Cleveland
Browns the gift that keeps on giving
whether they're good or not there's
always stuff to write about Cleveland
Plain Dealer for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]